wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
baby how could this feeling be wrong
sometimes the thing that you've been
searching for
has been right there the whole time
so baby i'm here to tell ya i'm waiting
right here just to make
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i always been here baby standing
right here by your side
yes
been building up inside of me
and i just gotta come out
and tell you what i'm feeling girl tell
you our love is what i'm talking about
[Music]
i finally need to show you my arms are
wide open that's where you belong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes the thing you're searching for
has been there the whole time
[Music]
[Applause]
against your big bald head your big bald
head i'll shed your big bald head in the
knot there's no one else i could be
possibly talking about cause you are
bald and you are here
[Music]
you
you're a woman i'm a man now you
and you know that's how i like it
and i'm specifically talking about you
because you're a girl and i am the
opposite woman woman woman woman
you are a woman i am a man
you know i like women you because i am a
man
never liked a man in my life for you
and i don't like one now